what was most satisfying to us in this
whole process was the opportunity to
design a public building that of
significance in Singapore
[Music]
we have created a very user-centric
accessible open Courthouse here in
Singapore
the relationship between the city and
its Civic buildings was our primary
entrance for this project in Chinatown
where the building is cited there are
two typical architecture one is the
ubiquitous high-rise and in close
proximity a shophouse our response was
to rethink the traditional Courthouse
technology in a high-rise building a
conceive it not as a singular building
but as two towers that each have a very
clear function an office tower is given
to the judicial offices while the
courthouse sit on a separate Tower which
is the public interface connected by
languages that allows judicial offices
to move between the offices and the
courtrooms
our Engineers had to come up with a very
Innovative engineering solution to
provide stability to address strong wind
loads and by this they have actually
utilized 39 languages that we had to
brace the slander Tower with the larger
court tower
we created a outdoor landscape Terraces
not just to enjoy the plants but I think
more importantly we created places of
respite where Court users can find peace
and come before the legal proceedings
begin
the tower also respond in the weight of
the south of the courtroom expressed the
Striking moves of the surrounding Shop
houses which are very visible from the
high-rise buildings in the neighborhood
today it is the tallest public building
here in Singapore and one of three
tallest court buildings in the world by
this we believe the state court Towers
can well become a president for future
public buildings here in Singapore
when it comes to high-rise high density
architecture Singapore really has the
capacity and the environment that
nurtures and promotes Innovation more
than almost any other City around the
world and also how we chooses to boldly
confront this issue instead of being
limited by it so the state courts Tower
contributes to Singapore's commitment to
create and Foster high-rise buildings
that are also environmentally
responsible